the whole night was magical eva longoria
tied the knot with her husband Jose Pepe
Antonio based on last month in Mexico on
Wednesday the 41 year old actress opened
up to et at her restaurant beso during
the after-party for her new film
lowriders where she dished on her
wedding the dress and falling in love
again what I knew about you from what I
knew about you
you know how to throw a party it was
magical Ricky Martin jumped up and sang
livin la vida loca and one of his old
menudo songs a Carlos Vives sang our
first dance song that was a surprise
Vanessa Williams sang right saved the
best for last we were standing at the
altar and here's the song saved the best
for last and I was like I turn around
and I do that I was like oh my god how
long did you work on the dress because I
know you and Victoria collaborate it
took about a month about a little over a
month it was so much fun because I when
I was in London that victoria pulled out
every single dress she's ever made and i
felt like
little girl in the best wardrobe ever
how did you open yourself back up to say
okay I'm gonna be able to love again oh
I was I've always been oh really should
you're a homo school man yeah you should
fall in love as many times yeah I've
never been closed off or afraid of it
even after failure does every failure
all right I'm just not I was never that
tortured just wearing your band you're
not wearing that love making my movie no
I'm back come to the band now I'm a
simple girl my engagement was a it's
even too much for me so I couldn't wait
to order just the band's how good does
it feel to say I love I just sounds good
rolls off your tongue it's a good last
name
fast on are you gonna use your
professional have you change the one you
know what can you change your name
nobody uses it so I'm gonna I'm gonna do
Eva Longoria bust okay we'll see we'll
all start the campaign and now manager
I'm gonna every time I see you I'm gonna
call you Eva Longoria buddy